The Joe Rogan experience. Well, I
read about you a fellow Boston native,
and I've read about your
Tesla journey and I was like,
this is a fucking interesting story.
This guy buys a broken Tesla, right?
And then you couldn't get
parts for it anywhere. Nope.
So what had happened to the car had
been in an accident? No. So the, I,
I met the previous owner
and he actually has,
I think it was during Hurricane Sandy.
Oh. He thought that, uh, he goes,
wait a minute, that water level seems
low enough for me to drive through it.
And he just said to driving through the
water, I think it got up to like the, uh,
almost like the B pillar.
Oh No. Like where his neck,
his, yeah. And Jesus Christ.
Yeah, I know. Right. So he thought he
could fight the water. He lost obviously,
and um, it was just under water
and I'm like, you know what,
I've got to try this thing. And so what,
what would Tesla do in that situation?
If he wanted to bring it back to them?
They would have to rebuild the entire car.
They wouldn't even do it because at that
point, uh, once, uh, anything liquid,
you know, any kind of like water
intrusion happens at an EMV phase. Right.
The whole car off insurance
companies just like,
we're not going to do with too
risky. Too risky. Not Worth it. We,
you aware of the Fisker a dilemma at
the hurricane sandy when they had a,
the Fiskars that were parked at the,
it was like at a, some sort of a doc.
Right. They ought to ship.
They all exploded. Yeah.
They'll burn the water level.
Rose, the water got into them and they
just went off and they fucking firewalls.
The whole bunch of them. Yeah.
Look, this is a video of it.
You can watch the video of
them fucking blowing up.
So as the water level rose and the hurt,
you'd see the water breaching. Yeah.
Well the water gets to the cars
and when it gets to the cars,
they just start going off like fucking
fireball. Oh yeah. I know that feeling.
Oh Wow. Look at that. Boom, boom, boom.
I knew
it was like a supernova.
I mean those are big ass fucking
batteries. Just blowing the fuck. Chokes.
It turns night in the day.
It's amazing how many,
they lost like 40 cards with me that
they lost a fuck load and the company
essentially went, they went radio
silent. Yeah. For like a year.
That's a big L to take.
Yeah.
Once people realize their car could just
explode out, that's not good. Sorry,
what happened? This kid, this video part,
I didn't look at the name of the video.
I popped up when I type it
into the Fisker explosion,
but this was the explosion of the con Ed
plant. Oh, that's a big difference. Yeah.
That was a John [inaudible] cars.
But there is a video of the actual
Fiskars exploding isn't their thing.
There's definitely pictures. Pictures.
The second video won't be as exciting.
Now let's leave it off.
Fuck it this more.
This is information set us back an hour.
So that's the cars.
That's what was left of them.
Wow. And they all fucking blew up.
It's a beautiful car though.
Fisker did a great job of making a car.
That looks really good. Right?
But you know what's funny, I,
I think the backends kind of ugly to
you think the front looks like a fish.
The back kind of ugly and then
actually, have you ever driven one? No.
You've been in one? No. When you
drive one you'll be like, ah,
I get why this didn't work out well
Justin Bieber had all chrome one.
I remember that. Yeah. Does he still
have it though? Cause you still have it.
He probably, he probably
doesn't even know. Yeah,
he probably doesn't know at this point.
Yeah.
You know the amount of money
that dude myself, yeah,
probably has no idea if he has that car.
No kidding.
It's got it tucked away somewhere. But
what do they drive? Like they're just,
they're just not really great cars.
It's not really a driver's car.
It's a two plus two. The a the center
console thing. Like you're closer to,
sorry that. Sorry. You can move around
if you want to take away the, uh,
the center console is super wide.
It's a super awkward car to drive and
it's not really good at really anything,
you know, it doesn't styling wise
I'm like, oh there we go. Yeah.
So you think that back end looks ugly?
I don't think I could that much. No, no.
I like it. But you know what's funny?
The Chromos and looked that bad.
Some guy got arrested in Germany.
They pulled them over and it compounds
it his car cause he had a gold shiny wrap
on it. It was a two reflective
or something. I see now
there's a couple on sunset,
like a Lamborghini or something.
They'll let you do that in America,
but in Germany they're like fuck off.
I took that Shit Bro. You
know they're like harsh, cold,
stoic folk.
They don't want you doing that.
And then I want you flexing too
much over there. Not Too much. No,
I bet they were like reluctantly are
making cars like super flashy for like
American markets and shit. I think
so too. I, you know, I wonder.
You think so? I don't know.
I don't know. Yeah, me,
I wonder how much of an influence it has.
Like if you could leave
them to themselves, right.
What kind of crops did
they make? Yeah. Yeah.
Cause I feel like so much of it
as like market driven, but they,
when it comes to like engineering and
handling like God damn German cars have it
nailed. They really do. They really do.
But you know what the Americans are,
they were trying to sneak up
and get clothes for a while.
But I mean like the German, just
to this, this, this, the standard,
the benchmark for every police with
the Americans fuck with it is like,
have you ever driven a
Camaro? Zl One I have. Yeah.
That's a preposterous car. It's an awesome
car. It's amazing. I have a, um, uh,
a corvette [inaudible] Ooh.
Which year ends that, oh, six
Oh six, which is, you know,
the ls seven seven liter.
And uh, it's an insane Chi.
By today's standards. It only has like
505 horsepower. Funny. But like, it's,
it's not a lot. It's a meme.
It's a mean car. The car,
I'll put you on your ass really
quick, man. Talking to a man,
our friend Taylor out there was telling
us that they put a Tesla in ludicrous
mode on a dyno and it had
some insane number of Torque,
900 pound pound feet of
Torque and somewhere in the
neighborhood of a thousand
horsepower and the dyno
could barely even read it.
A lot of times they even go that
high and a lot of cases, yeah,
they're insane cars, man. I'm telling
you, the Americans know how to do it now.
I think it's interesting that you know,
people don't realize this
when they see a Tesla,
it's a fully American car and they don't
realize that. They're just like, oh,
it's probably something like,
you know, German or Japanese car,
but the car is 100% made here. Is
this it right here, Jamie? Yes.
Is this the,
which model is this?
[inaudible] so that's the biggest one.
So what does it say on a Mustang Dyno?
So we're going to go from like a 20 mile
an hour roll sound like these little
boys will tell you this Tesla up here
trying to figure out how fast she goes.
I think I'm getting to jump. I thought I
said 56 seconds. Yeah, no, I think it, uh,
look at a community and even almost
jumps off the diner at this point.
There's so much torque.
Yeah. It's a very,
very, very powerful car.
What I've tried to describe it to people,
especially people that have never
driven an electric car, I'm like,
it doesn't even seem real.
It seems like it violates physics.
So how do you like yours,
by the way? So I know,
I know that Ilan mosque came here and
bamboozle you into buying one pretty much.
How do you, how dare you?
I love it. I love it.
It's great, isn't it? It makes other cars
seemed stupid. Right? And I love cars.
Oh yeah. I know. You're
a car guy. I love them.
I love cars that don't
even drive that fast.
I love mechanical engineered excellence.
I love that when people figure
things out, right? Yeah.
Which is what brought me to you.
I love the fact that you took this
car that was fucked up, right?
And you refuse to let it go.
You like,
I'm going to figure out how
to fix this fucking thing.
How much did you buy it for? It was 15
grand. Just to be clear on something.
I'm not like some like
evil genius or brainiac.
This was driven by my cheapness because
I didn't want to spend the kind of money
they were asking for one,
right? So, so basically this
car is like 15 grand. And um,
the whole story started
with my friend came over,
he actually had a job at Tesla and he's
like, buddy, listen, do these crazy cars.
Uh, I knew you have a zero six
but there's cars faster than that.
You're going to love this thing. I
was like, that electric crap box.
I don't want anything to do with that.
Whatever. Right? You brought the car over,
great looking car. I said, all right,
and I'll take it for a drive or whatever.
And the thing was amazing,
right? Amazing car.
So I was in tech and I'm just
like, listen, like, you know what,
how much does this thing cost?
Like I make decent money, whatever.
I'll just throw some money
at it. And he's like, listen,
this is the cost about 120. I said,
you know what? Have a nice day.
I'm not buying that shit. Um, and then he,
so he left and I thought to myself like
every night I was like, you know what?
I got to get my hands on one of these
cars, man. I gotta get one like, you know,
sell a kidney, whatever. I sell a
testicle or whatever I can do. And it's,
I was searching online and you know,
at what happens is whenever a car
gets messed up, whenever a car gets a,
as I say total in a way, and it's
a total loss and insurance company,
you'll take it and they'll kind of
auction it off to like the highest bidder.
So I went to an auction site and I saw
one for sale was like, you know, 15 grand.
They said it didn't run her drive and
it wasn't a flood and I'm just like 15
grand. I could do that. That's a piece
of cake, man. I threw some money at it.
Whatever. How hard can it be? You stick
it in a bag of rice and I tie it up.
He's like an iPhone, you know, you've
got a rifle in the toilet right here.
What I mean it's,
it's like all had socks.
You want a bag of rice and you get to go.
So I figured out how to do it is by
more rice for this thing. And uh,
I got home and um, I was like,
you know what, this is a,
I got myself into some shit here cause uh,
this,
it was a lot more work than I thought
I was going to be sight unseen. Nope.
Sight unseen. That's, that's
the way it is the most times.
They don't really let you on
the auction lots too often.
So they took five photos of it.
It was sent from the interior,
some from the side and I'm one
under the front and I was just like,
I could probably do this. Right, no
big deal. So this begins his project,
which takes how long to completion?
I think it took me about maybe six or
seven months or so of straight work. No.
So I have, um, so I was
working at the time and uh,
I think only between the hours of like
7:00 PM and like 11:00 PM like every
night and then weekends for a few
hours until I figured it out. Yeah.
So goodbye social life
pretty much. Yeah. I was,
I was a hermit for there for those months.
And what actually ended up doing was,
so I had the car right. So I was freaking
out because my wife was just like,
how much was that thing? And like,
you know what I mean? Of course. Yeah.
She had a divorce papers
ready pretty much. And uh, oh,
I know this was a different one. Yeah.
Fuck yeah, that was really messed up.
Now I couldn't say if I want to get that
one for that one was about guests for
grand 20 grand. I paid for that. Yes. Yes.
Total. Yeah, I know. But these,
they're so valuable man. Really?
Because you know why it's the,
the,
the battery technology on the motor
technology that tussle is using.
Everyone's just dying for that
stuff, man. That's so any, any,
any rec test so that you find minimum,
I know I'm spilling the secret sauce here.
Minimum Worth 15 grand. Even if it looks
like that. Dead serious. That's insane.
What that thing doesn't even have doors
yet. Still we took, I took the doors off,
took the doors off, put the battery
pack is still in there. Right.
And the multitudes and the
motor was still in there too.
Do people take those and put them in like
old cars or anything yet? Absolutely.
It's a he that's the new
generation of hot rodders man.
Cause you saw something like that
about a Mustang. It was like a 65,
66 Mustang that was electric, but I
didn't know what train it used. So,
so you know how um,
you're a gearhead,
you know this is the ls swap.
They put literally an ls into everything.
Yeah. I a landscape land cruiser,
Toyota Land Cruiser with one
ls, swap went. Oh Shit. Um,
so that's the new ls swap basically.
So the Tesla Motor is the new ls swap.
Everyone is swapping the Tesla motor
until you know Volkswagen bugs into Audis,
into, into Porsche's, into everything.
Well I know that people were doing ls
swaps into nine 11 and Porsche people are
losing their fucking minds. I now
take an old air cooled cars. Yep.
Which are really notoriously difficult
to get to a high horsepower. Exactly.
Cause those air cooled cars,
like you can only get them like
around 400 plus horsepower.
These stay stocked crumbling
unless your singer, right?
Well they've got that insanely engineered
a new one. What is that called?
Lionel lakes call. Either way it's
going to cost you like you know,
damn near $100,000 sitting at 80 power,
something dynamic, lightweight, something.
It's the most gorgeous looking of those
portions have ever seen ever. Sanders.
And they built that one up to 500
plus horsepower. Right? That's Hammad.
How much does it cost though? That's the
thing. Fucking million. 6,000,006. Yeah.
You can buy one. That's a giant
house, man. That's a house with land.
You might have a, well actually that's not
true. And in La that's not a house. No.
But la is not the real world. What
is that? 67 Mustang meets Tesla.
Avr Motors, all electric muscle
car. Holy Fuck. That's a 68.
That's a good looking too.
That's one of the best looking rear ends
of any car ever. An awesome looking God.
Fuck. That looks
incredible. 2.2 to 60. Yeah,
there you go. What the fuck? So that's
a new, that's a new one. So there's,
it was going to cost
you a ton of work that
it's going to cost you a ton of
money to recreate that same look.
God with the look has this nice screen
to what did, that's so weird though,
to not shift a muscle car. I'm thinking
I'm out. I'm out. I'm backing out.
But you love your Tufts,
although you don't shift that,
but it doesn't look like that. That
would be a super ultra poser. Right?
The door handles come out
like a test all the way.
It doesn't the Tesla
doorhandles Oh fuck off next.
No, no, no. There's a company that
does, um, it's a company called Rev.
Ology that makes old like
1966 to like 68 mustangs.
But they do it with all new parts and
modern technical resto mod pretty much not
though because it's a new car there.
They buy the full, um, that's uh,
that's actually a brand new car
that's never existed. Oh really? Yeah.
It's a ground up build, ground up built.
They buy the whole, you know, cause it's,
I think it's called a unibody
construction. Is that what
it is? There's something,
the way that these
mustangs are constructed,
the body's built into the frame and
they bought this company sells them like
completed versions of the body kit that
are perfect with perfect tolerances.
Right. So like that. Like it's cool. Like
that's one, there's 67 Shelby gt 500.
What's the pricing? Oh Wow. Stupid
expensive. Yeah. It's not gonna work.
It's like two Teslas. Yeah, pretty
much. Yeah. But they're dope.
It's dope as fuck. If you look at
like what it looks like, go down,
see some pictures of it, Jamie, you'd
get a better, better sense of it.
But this guy is, that's meticulous.
Yeah. This company is very meticulous.
I'm, I've been following their stuff for
quite awhile and what they do is really
incredible. Right? That's an all met all
new sheet metal. I can, everything's new,
but it has some killer brakes and it
has a modern Coyote Mustang engineer,
right?
Fibo Yup.
So it's a 460 horsepower engine
in these old badass muscle cars.
And that one's the gt 500 that
was actually super charged.
That is a 600 horsepower engine that
it's dope. They're fucking gorgeous.
They're gorgeous cars.
There's really pretty so,
so what would you think about someone
dropping an electric motor on one of these
things? See, I love it. Look, I
love, I love people doing crazy shit,
but it's not for me.
I need to shift if I'm driving that thing,
I got to pretend I'm Steve
McQueen. I hear you man. Oh Oh.
Basic thing. So what do you think about
the new, you seen the new Tesla roadster,
right? Gorgeous. What do you
think about it? I love it. Yeah,
but it's theirs from the bottom up.
You know what I'm saying? It's like,
I don't mind not shifting in it.
That thing seems like it's going to
literally punch a hole through space time.
Yeah,
I think so too.
I think they're looking at it like
zero to 60 in like one point something
seconds. I think it's one nine. That's
what they're saying. It's insane.
That's bizarre. I know. It's crazy when
you feel it in the p 100 deep mine.
Like everybody that I get in the car
and I stomp on the gas, they're like,
they can't believe it. They can't
believe that these are around you.
It's like it's like vampires
being around people.
But people that just leap to the top
abilities that walking around can regular
until some shit goes down.
Yeah. No, they're, they're
absolutely amazing cars, man.
And I think that's the main reason why I
was like, I gotta get one of these man.
So what was the struggle? Initial
struggle. You have the car,
you take it apart and what did you see?
It's pretty much,
I was kind of taking my time because I
knew there was a point where I couldn't
fix the damn thing. And I've just kind
of wasting everyone's time. Wife's like,
Hey, is this thing almost done? I was
like, yeah, babe, don't worry about it.
We're good. Don't worry.
Your money's safe. And, um,
so there's a certain point where I took
everything apart and I was like, alright,
cool. I found a dead fish in the
back of the car. So actually,
you know what the turning point,
this whole thing was that the
turning point yeah. Was, um, I,
I realized it was salt water and
not fresh water. So, you know what?
Saltwater does this stuff, right? So it
just, it just kills everything. So, uh,
90% of the car was kind of toast.
And, uh, I said to myself, all right,
I'm going to call Tesla, you know, buy
a motor by a battery pack, I'll be good.
You know what I mean?
Maybe I'll spend like 20 grand for a
battery and like maybe 10 for a motor,
I'll be filling for 40. It's still
cheaper than a hundred. Right, right. So,
so I called them up and uh, you
know, they were like, hey, you know,
how's it going man? I was like, Hey, you
know what a crazy thing happened, right?
So I bought this tussles under water
and um, I need like a couple of things.
I need a battery, I need like a motor,
you know, just, just told me those things,
it's fine. They're like, well,
we're not going to sell it.
To was like, well why not?
Because you have no capability of
fixing the car yourself. You know,
you're going to get yourself killed.
It's not going to work. You know,
give me your vin number. And I gave
him the Vin number. They're like, no,
that car is listed as salvage.
That thing was underwater.
We're not going to help you. And they
just hung up the phone pretty. Ooh. Yeah.
So like this is the crazy part
two is that they know, you know,
I'm putting my conspiracy theorist hat on.
They know where every single car is.
They know what it's doing.
They know if the airbags went off,
they know if you farted the front seat,
they know everything about these cars.
So pretty much when you give
them the vin number, you know,
the cars are always kept it back to the
mothership to give you the status in the
car so they know what's going on. So
you know, if you try to hide from you,
just you just can't do it.
Um, so, so I had the, I had
the car and I said to myself,
you know what? This isn't going to
work. I've got to figure something out.
So what I did,
basically I bought another car
for 15 grand and I was like,
I got to swap this stuff over.
So I saw,
so the other one that you bought for
15 grand, everything worked well.
He was on a end collision.
Okay.
It wasn't a hard front end collision
and the frame's bent or something.
Rain was banned to thing was toast and
I just took all the electronics from one
to the other. How do you check to make
sure that everything is damaged again?
Well,
that's a good thing.
A lot of the wiring harnesses were cut
right in the front end collision car.
But the interesting part was that in
the flooded car, the wiring harnesses,
we're still good for the most part in
the front really. So what I did was,
I mean meaning not broken or
torn or have Ben connectors,
I just took those connectors off and
actually clean them because they couldn't
get parts, you know, from Tesla.
And I took like the wet wiring
harnesses that we're all corroded,
pulled them out, got like, you know,
a Qtip toothbrush and all that
stuff he cleaned them with.
So I cleaned them with um,
with baking,
speaking soda and I'm like a wire
brush and like I got a toothpick to,
to really get in there and like
cleaning the contacts and stuff.
I just rinsed them out with water. By this
time your wife was probably like, what?
She's pissed. She goes, I noticed we're
missing $30,000 from our bank account
and two cars that don't work exactly
to printers don't work, you know,
and if there is a $30,000 missing
from our bank account, like,
what's going on here? So, um, it was
just, it was painstaking, but eventually,
you know, I got the job done then, so, so
I ended up doing was so 30 grand, right.
I told my friends, hey listen, you know,
I'm in a mess here and we're building
a test on it. Just like, you know,
you're an idiot, you're not going to
figure this out. Like no one's doing that.
Cause this was,
this was years ago,
this is when the cars were still kind of
coming onto the scene and they weren't
as popular as they are now. And like you
can't fix that. Like you're an idiot,
you can't do that. I've
seen your work. And uh,
so yeah, so after a while, you know,
I took all the parts from
one to the other, um,
got one running and then the
parts I didn't need anymore,
like the, like the old battery
pack and some of the action.
So there were some parts of the
battery that we're still good.
So I actually sold those parts like
online and on Ebay and stuff like that.
And then I sold like the motor,
he had water in it. Someone got,
give me five grand for a
motor that had water in it.
That's how valuable these parts are.
So mad.
Was he planning on doing the same
thing with cleaning it out? I,
I have no idea to this day. I don't know.
So I think he has in the same situation.
I think he brought it home to his
wife. He's like, hey look what I got.
I'd probably still at his house and uh,
so after all of that,
so all of the parts I ended up getting
the car I have now for about six grand.
So you take the engine and is that
one of the four wheel drive ones?
The ones you have.
This was just the rear wheel drive one.
And so it has just the rear engine.
The single motor. Yep. One engine.
And so you take those out,
you put it all back in,
you'll replace the wires and then it's
good to go. What about the computer?
What about, Gosh, so pretty much the,
the computer thing was interesting because
there was, so I called Tesla again,
right? I was like, hey buddy, like
this car is like 99% of the way there.
Do you know,
do they know who you are at this point?
They still don't know who I am.
Nor did they care.
They still probably don't care who
I am but, but did you say, hey man,
you remember you hung up on me? Like
yeah, right. The car still doesn't work.
Well still didn't work. Right.
So the tough part was I had to,
so remember I had no, I
had no key for the car. Oh.
So I was like, Hey, I need
a key. You know what I mean?
Like help me out here and get a
key. And they were like, well,
are you the same idiot that called my,
yeah, I need the key. They were like,
we can't, as I stated before, we
can't help you because you know this,
this is a salvage car, so you're on your
own. So what I did was I actually in the,
in the GPS screen, because
the screen turned on the, the,
the guy still had the home location.
So I pushed home on the GPS screen.
Found the guy's address, right?
This is creepy. I gets creepy,
right? Found the guy's address.
And I was like, Hey, you know,
can we, uh, I called
them up. I was like, hey,
did you own like a white Tesla by
chance? And he's like, who is like,
yeah, I own one. I was like, yeah,
um, so I bought it and I need the key.
Do you have the key to the
car? And he's like, no, I
don't, I don't have that. Like,
what do you call me for like,
I don't understand is like,
well, I'm rebuilding it,
I'm putting the electronics from
your condo or another, and, um,
I want to figure it out. And he's
like, you know what, I can't help you.
I don't have the key. And I was like,
damn socks, you know, cause you know,
I have a family and stuff and you know,
kind of give him the sob story, like,
you know, he could really look for and
helped me out would be good. And, uh,
we started talking about general topics
and he's like, you know, you know,
I know you're a car guy.
That's awesome. Um, I had, uh,
I had a zero six once and I was like,
Hey, I have a zero six two. And he's like,
yeah, it was, it was Le Mans blue. And
I was like, Hey, mines the mines blue.
And he's like, what year is it? I
was like, it's an o six. He goes,
I sold that same car or car like it
like two years ago to a guy in Florida.
I was like, I bought the car from a
guy in Florida. So we started bonding.
So it turns out I actually owned his
old six. Yeah, it's crazy. Right?
What are the odds of two
human beings on the planet?
You own both of this guy's car pulls of
this guy's car. It wasn't. It was insane.
So he's like, listen. He goes, hey,
awesome. You know, I'll see if I could,
I'll see if I could find, you know,
the key friends with that dude. No, no,
we never talked again after that. I
was like, you should be free. Well,
here's the reason why.
So he, Hey, well one,
it was super creepy for me to
call the guy in. Number two. Um,
when I went, you know, I went
kind of silent for a week,
he called me back and said, buddy, I found
the key. Oh, I found the key to the car.
I was like, awesome dude.
Like, you're fantastic.
I'm going to send you an envelope to
your address so you could kind of give me
the key. And he's like, yeah, yeah, great,
great, great. How about like 600 bucks?
And I was like, Bro, Haim,
we just bonded over the fact
that I owned both of your cars.
What are you doing to me here? 600.
Yeah, 16. I remember like, you know,
to a lot of people that's nothing but
like to me like I was trying to be cheap
and scrappy sometimes a bit much.
600 bucks. Yeah, that's a bit much.
A lot of money. And I was like,
Hey, I was like, you didn't,
the key didn't exist to you as of a week
ago, but now you can make money from it.
Like now you want to talk
to 100 bucks? And he's just
like, you know, you know, Dah,
Dah, Dah. I be talking again and he goes,
how about 400 bucks? And I was like,
you know, a guy, I'll just
just give you the money.
Just take the damn money and blood money.
Yeah. Right, exactly right. So I sold,
I sold my soul pretty much. And he did.
Yeah. He's got that blood money. No,
but I shouldn't have, I feel like
I was, I shouldn't have taken it.
I would've rubbed that money
on my balls. [inaudible] Bro.
Make sure you sniff that hundred dollar
bill first. I mean, it's, look, I get it.
He's just being a dirt bag. Right. But
no, but after that you got the key and um,
it's, it's, that's what it is. And then
the car's running and driving today.
So as soon as you got the
key, you're good. Do you have
one key or two? Just one.
Oh, if I lose that, I'm screwed. Can you
make, does the phone work like your APP?
Does it work on the car? Nope. Damn. No,
that's big. That after this huge, yeah,
I, let's go then you get the car to
come to you. You can summon it. Yeah.
You can park like, like literally than
branch on each side. Right? That's the
[inaudible].